scorn's entire intent seems to be to
disgust disturb and unnerve the player
with its terrifying imagery of fleshy
holloways and unsettling biomechanical
monstrosities and to that Benchmark the
game seems to very much succeed this is
a game that I and my normally fairly
strong gag reflex has struggled to look
at from the earliest trailer it's a
gross looking game that Delights in its
grossness and scoring you play as an
unnamed person has become isolated in an
unnerving place where viscous looking
living tissue and twisted mechanical
Contraptions have been combined in an
uncanny relationship that seems
symbiotic in nature there are some
moments of first person shooting and
elements of horror and Scorn but the
game is more focused on puzzle solving
and exploration not action or scares
scorn has an incredible visual style
this game has been immediately
recognizable for me since its original
2014 reveal the not quite living but
definitely not dead nature to everything
curates this uncanny sense that the
protagonist is never truly alone even
the very walls give up the impression
that they may be watching you funneling
you towards something eerie and terrible
scoring looks and sounds like my
favorite kind of horror game an
experience that is going to genuinely
unnerve you not try to make you afraid
with frequent jump scares the sick part
of my brain that loves games like that
can't get enough of what scorn looks and
sounds like
oh
foreign
further supports the unsettling
sensation of scorn's imagery but it
seems to largely contribute to ebb
software's goal for the game to be an
experience built with Discovery and
exploration principally in mind there
doesn't seem to be anyone or anything in
scorn that will tell you what to do or
give you a detailed explanation of
what's going on there's very little in
the way of any sort of guidance there's
not much in the way of narrative setup
either so you don't really understand
where you are or what you're supposed to
be doing you have to discover that for
yourself searching for The Way Forward
by finding solutions to puzzles I assume
the goal in scorn is to escape wherever
you are whether that's hell and alien
planet some terrifying Vision or
something else entirely but I generally
could not tell you if that's the case
the game gives you nothing relying on
your blind curiosity to encourage you
forward this isn't altogether a novel
concept from software soulsborne games
or perhaps some of the best known
examples of games that do a lot of
showing and almost never tell tasking
players are spending dozens of hours
piecing together what's happened prior
to the start of the story and how that
relates to what you're supposed to do
next and there are plenty of other
examples where the narrative through a
line is difficult to discern especially
early on in the story like Hollow Knight
limbo and Legend of Zelda breath of the
wild scorn however may be a bit too
opaque in its storytelling and level
design it's definitely too soon to say
for sure Gamespot was only shown the
opening section of the game for this
preview so there's a good chance that
scoring's plot and what you're supposed
to do in order to beat the game becomes
a lot more coherent later on regardless
it's too unfair to judge an entire game
based on the opening minutes so I'm not
going to do that but I can critique what
I have seen and that has largely been a
game where I'm confused as to what the
player is striving for my big issue with
that is that it doesn't exactly convince
me to want to see more maybe I'm just
missing a hidden detail or two but I'm
not getting any sense that scoring has a
story Beyond being lost in an unsettling
World ideally I want a little bit more
like a mystery to solve or threat to
defeat or moral to learn and granted
scorn could include any or all of those
narrative threads but the game doesn't
seem to even be hinting at any of them
from the get-go so instead scorn seems
like a showcase for the truly disturbing
world that ebb software has created
while that world is intriguing and seems
interesting enough to explore for a
while I'm not convinced that such a
surface level of curiosity can pull me
in for a full game there could be
something really cool in regards to
scorn and I hope that there is but if
it's there ebb software has done such a
good job hiding it the studio has
effectively kept me from becoming
invested in the game as incredible as
the visuals and audio for scoring are
for now they aren't enough for me I want
a little bit more narrative meat on
these gross looking bones